[Music]
deutschingen agricultural equipment
company is tough
it's Capital intensive and cash-strapped
Farmers tend to be a conservative lot
but california-based Monarch which has
raised 116 million dollars in equity
from investors and reached a valuation
of 271 million dollars in November 2021
at its latest Equity funding seems to
have hit a Tipping Point last year it
booked 22 million in Revenue up from
just 5 million in 2021 this year
co-founder and CEO pravia pen Meza
expects Revenue to increase three to
five-fold as it expands he expects that
more of its Revenue will come from
software subscriptions which cost up to
eight thousand three hundred and seventy
six dollars per tractor per year the
software gives Farmers real-time alerts
how things like sick plants and safety
risks and it gathers and crunches a ton
of data to improve crop yields
those numbers helped Monarch make the
cut for this year's Forbes next billion
dollar startups list our annual Showcase
of the 25 companies we think most likely
to reach a one billion dollar evaluation
every farmer around the world is under
tremendous pressure because of lack of
Labor with this labor shortage they're
also being asked to do more because a
transition to sustainable regenerative
Farm practices
requires Farmers to do more operations
in the field instead of spraying once
with dangerous chemicals they have to do
more mechanical operations like mowing
or weeding that is going to cost them
more in diesel
more in labor which is what is holding
that transition back so that's the
second big challenge that farmers are
facing the third big one is people
asking for data from the farm whether
it's Regulatory Agencies certifying
agencies that are looking to certify
organic sustainable practices or even
consumers like you and me wanting to
know more about how this fruit or
vegetable that I bought was farmed all
of this means that now the farmer has to
go and collect data on the farm at a
time when there's no labor and
collecting data is going to result in
more emissions from diesel equipment
Monarch targets Vineyards and Fruit and
Vegetable Farms for its tractors these
require smaller machines than the giant
ones used by those who raise corn or
soybeans
we are the only all-electric smart
driver optional tractor in the world
that farmers can buy today and the fact
that it's all electric uh really helps
the farmers out in reducing their fuel
costs it also helps us in reducing
emissions that comes from farming
the way we view the system is kind of
three main elements so there's a fully
electrified and by wire platform in some
sense it's actually the lower half of
the tractor is fully electric and fully
by wire controlled so that means that we
have electronic control over everything
that the tractor does we are enabled to
learn what a human operator a skilled
human tractor driver is doing because we
see all the inputs that they are putting
into the system when they're doing a
specific operation out on the farm and
that knowledge then we can feed up into
the autonomy system to say this is how
your skilled human operator ran a mowing
operation or ran a spraying operation
and that information now we can encode
and start to learn from so the some of
the artificial intelligence is really
learning what the human operators are
doing and then applying that to allow
the system to recreate those same
operations but in a fully autonomous
fashion so the base platform is
electrified and fully by wire are
controlled and then that connects to the
roof or kind of the top half of the
tractor and in the roof we have all of
our computation and communication and
sensors the understanding of what the
system is doing and all of the heavy
computation to decide what to do with
the tractor where to go how to stay
centered in a row turn it around at the
end of a row all of that detail how to
get from point A to point B how to do an
operation correctly all of that is is
encoded in the roof and in the software
that's running at the edge in the root
the third layer in the system is the
digital elements of the system or the
cloud-based elements of the system that
data from one tractor in a fleet is
reported up to the cloud lessons that we
learned from one tractor from watching
One driver we can learn that lesson
transmit it up to the cloud and then
reapply that lesson across the entirety
of our Fleet
big I think like huge opportunity is
this autonomy feature we as Farmers
every single day during the growing
season when there's fungal pressure
which there is in every Farm region
around the world we have to put on
hazmat suits and to spray chemicals to
deal with fungal pathogens and even with
Organic contact sprays right you still
have to wear a mask and all this just
with a safe day by day everything going
smoothly you're exposing yourself a lot
then there's also the dangers of terrain
and things that could happen so by being
able to automate farming we're removing
the operator from the most dangerous
place in the farm and we're elevating
them into a much happier healthier
cleaner safer lifestyle so data is is
massively important there's a great
McKinsey and Company study that has come
out and said that by 2050 Farms will be
70 percent more productive because of
data so it's reactionary it's the
ability to implement changes like if you
have disease pressure in a part of your
Vineyard or you part of your farm your
orchard you can catch that earlier and
hopefully mitigate a plant from
potentially having to be replaced to
actually just having to make a couple
cuts and you're fine that plant Will
Survive the greater data that we can get
the more productive we can be as Farmers
the farm owner now is seeing the big
picture view and they're saying okay
I've Offset you know this many kilograms
of CO2 I have these five issues in my
field that have been automatically
identified you know I'm seeing the
beginning of a pest or of a fungus or
something thing I'm starting to see the
beginning of that because that data is
starting to be reported back so kind of
at all three of those levels at the
operator at the kind of farm manager and
at the farm owner the insights that the
system is providing are enabling all
three of those people to do their jobs
better and to basically spend less time
to get more work done
what we are seeing with our farm
customers is for the first time in
agriculture as well a lot of them have
purchased multiple tractors some of them
have bought 10 17 tractors at a time in
their first year that tells us two
things the fact that they're willing to
buy a number of tractors in the first
year of production tells us that their
challenges are real and huge word number
two they're also looking at a tractor as
a solution for some of these challenges
and the fact that we can actually
address these challenges for them I
think is the game changer so we are
essentially creating new revenue streams
for the farmer in this new world of
sustainable farming and carbon credits
for agriculture we are saving them Opex
in terms of diesel savings and also in
terms of Labor efficiencies
I come from a world when you know phones
used to cost 20 30 dollars
now all of us are comfortable paying
more than a thousand dollars sometimes
for a phone the same thing has happened
with smart devices when we think about
thermostats or you know security
doorbells Smart Ones or security cameras
once we digitally transform or machine
the value provided to the end user is a
lot higher so we actually feel that our
tractor is Affordable in terms of fruits
and vegetables Farmers being able to
access the tech and get the savings but
long term there's nothing on this
tractor that prevents us from continuing
to drive the cost of the device down
to where every Farmer in the world can
eventually buy a tractor power with
Monarch technology or a monarch-like
tractor
[Music]
to keep up with demand last August
Monarch Inked to deal with Foxconn the
Taiwanese company famous for
manufacturing most of the world's
iPhones to make its SUV size tractors
it's also licensing its technology most
notably to cnh Industrial the
london-based outfit that is the second
largest tractor maker in the world I
never imagined in a million years that
I'd be involved in a technology company
although in farming we are using
technology all the time I always say
that farmers are the most Innovative
people on the planet we're constantly
reacting to a very changing environment
and climate change has made that even
more difficult because we're on the
front lines of everything that's
happening as Farmers with climate change
one thing you are right about is there
are risk overs because when you talk to
a farmer you we all have to realize that
we're talking to somebody who only gets
maybe 40 or 50 chances in their lifetime
from the time they get control of the
farm to when they have to give it to
them Next Generation so when we go in
there and ask them to change their
operations or make wholesale changes
that could put the whole farm at risk or
their production at risk they obviously
are risk hours from that standpoint but
they're not afraid of trying new things
I think the biggest thing that I've
learned about Farmers is how open they
are with what their issues are you don't
have to like wonder what what a former
is worried about or thinking about
they'll tell you exactly what they need
and if you can bring that solution to
them they'll adopt your product
Winery and Vineyard here in Livermore
California behind us is the vineyard
where their focus is right now are
growing great great grapes to make great
wine but now they can also Farm the
exact
energy that's growing their crops to
create energy to power their farm right
now it's estimated that farmers when
they spray are about 95 inefficient
meaning that five percent of the
fungicides or insecticides actually hit
the target by being able to slow down
through automation we're able to even if
we can increase that by to 30 efficient
that's a huge savings to Farmers and
even more importantly we're not asking
Farmers to set this up with huge amounts
of data entry if there's one thing that
farmers hate is it sitting and entering
data so our AI system that is powered by
all of these cameras and the computers
are sit on the roof we provide the
insights without the farmer having to
sit and do a lot of data entry on where
is this row located what is the row
number
what is happening on this road and the
farmer has the benefit of looking at it
on their mobile app or once they get
back home they can kind of fire up their
PC and look at that so these are all
things that really gives them full
access to the farm
from a digital standpoint and allows
them to make faster decisions
including an autonomous electric tractor
is difficult doing so at a price that
farmers can afford is even harder
in the early days monarchs Engineers
pitched a tent at wenty Vineyards to
develop and test the machine monarch
made only two at a cost of half a
million dollars each in 2021 it
introduced a second version that cost
250 000 and began testing with Vineyards
and Dairy Farmers to keep things simple
they focused first on automating one of
the most basic Farm tasks mowing
[Music]
the current production tractor is a
fourth or fifth generation of the
products with each iteration we
basically drove the cost down and also
Incorporated feedback from the prior
generation from testing in our own test
facility and primarily from testing with
customers if you actually look at the
generations of the product the second or
third generation from a technology
standpoint actually had significantly
more technology and more complexity and
as we put them in the field and Solomon
was working and saw what had high value
we started stripping that complexity out
of the system so in a sense we kind of
peaked on the complexity and then we
came back down to increase the customer
value and the robustness and drive the
cost down very quickly we realized that
all of our strengths had to be harnessed
together to really solve the problem
when we think about what Carlo brings to
the table he was a talk leader on
regenerative farming Mark brings his
skating experience and his past
experience from Tesla he had to deal
with the challenges of how do we build a
very complex machine at scale
and deliver it globally Zachary or
mahundro has been working on autonomy
especially off-road autonomy since 2005.
his past experience not only on autonomy
but also a past experience on agrobotics
on what the electrification of the
tractor could be and should be and my
past experience having seen what energy
transformation can do I was starting a
company in 2010 when energy security was
a new world
so I felt like starting Monarch tractor
was the right thing to do because I felt
like food security would be a challenge
for the future and today we live in that
world where food security is being heard
more and more often
so bringing everybody together to solve
the global challenge of how do we make
farming profitable and the food
ecosystem sustainable was easy because
we all bought into the mission first and
it seemed also like a natural team
for us to kind of start working together
[Music]
from a farming background I had no
experience in farming prior to starting
the uh the company
for me I looked at the farming space in
the lens of my experience which is
through manufacturing and supply chain
but also through electrification from an
electrification perspective there was
nothing in a farm that really had any
sort of electric propulsion system and
for that reason it was a wide open space
the other side of it was for me that
I've worked in factories for my entire
career and when I looked at a farm I
didn't really see a farm I saw a factory
for food I didn't really see
Manufacturing Technologies that we have
really had in factories for the last 40
years the way that we utilize things in
in factories it just didn't exist on
farms they didn't have the equipment
they didn't have the technology they
didn't have manufacturing discipline I
looked at that as an opportunity for
Farms to take all the technology that
we've had for 40 years in in factories
and applied to the Farms from an
automation perspective because in
factories people don't do that much in a
high volume environment anymore
thing about all of this data that we're
collecting into wingspan and making it
easy to use is we can also export this
data to all the different stakeholders
in agriculture and farming
so if there's an expert and Carlo and I
were actually doing this when Carlo was
in Europe recently and looking at some
of his Farms here
you know being able to show that data
and sharing that data with some of the
experts you know in Italy and talking to
them about what's happening in
California but with data and showing
them hey this is what it looks like at
this point and this is what's happening
really allows Farmers now to have access
to global experts in providing
recommendations
and that data can also be shared with
different partners on financing side
insurance agencies
fertilizer agencies a number of these
people can all come together to provide
these Solutions funding a hardware
company that is going into agriculture
and has an autonomy component to it is
always going to be challenging I
remember the days when some of one of
our early investors that I was pitching
to
call me a masochist he said you're
trying to go into a market that has not
seen much success
we can't name a billion dollar company
yet in agriculture Farmers right are
hard customers they are constantly
looking for Value before they they
purchase and scale
and more importantly autonomy and
automation is a deep Tech field
and they're combining all three which is
exactly what we did not because it was
easy to fund not because it was a
short-term fad
but because we saw an industry that was
ripe for transformation and we felt like
that industry would come to us that
being said the early years were quite
challenging
but over the last couple of years we are
actually starting to see more and more
investors start to see the same
opportunities that we are
kobit has actually accelerated some of
the mega Trends the labor shortages have
gotten worse food sustainability has has
really accelerated
and food security has become a common
term investors are seeing the same
themes so now they are much more
open to funding companies like ours so
funding fundraising has actually gotten
a lot easier over the last four years
and that is also reflected in our
valuation it's amazing because every
single person on this planet is
connected to agriculture you know it was
just I think 1900 half the population of
the United States was was a farmer now
it's 1.8 percent so there's been this
disconnect right there's a shifting
happening saying hey where does my food
come from we certainly have that in wine
where does this bottle of wine come from
how was the climate that year that made
it special right or what was the climate
that year that made this difficult not
good and I think that's transitioning
quickly into food people want to know
where their food comes from people want
to know how it was farmed people realize
that how their food was formed will
actually affect their gut microbiome and
their health it's another bit that's
really cool with mono tractors you're
able to absorb all this data and now you
can tell that story at the grocery store
foreign
there's just one problem charging
monarchs machines need to run for many
hours in fields Far From Any electrical
outlets or even roads
what potential solution is solar
charging but for now most of the robots
require access to a charging station
that could cost thousands of dollars to
install
our vehicle basically meets the existing
level 2 or AC charging protocol that is
now deployed throughout North America
for all of the existing on-road electric
vehicles so we're using an existing
standard so we can use all of that
existing infrastructure and because now
there's a good Supply base for kind of
the wall side units to provide that
charging power in terms of solar what we
are seeing is that many of the Farms
that we're working with either already
have or are planning to install on-site
solar on their Farms but many of these
installations are large scale right you
might have a farmer that's installing a
half megawatt solar array and that's
what makes economic sense for the given
farmer and so that solar array then is
feeding into the Grid at the farmer's
facility and then we are pulling power
off of that same grid of course there's
always you know in automotive you'd call
it range anxiety in in ag it's probably
more accurate to call it operating hour
anxiety or operations anxiety in terms
of will I have enough power to to run
the system that being said what we've
seen in real world application is that
the
battery size that we are providing is
sufficient to last for a full day of
operations for most of the operations
that the farmers are running some of the
generations earlier that was really
dialing in the battery capacity needed
to achieve a full day of operation and
so we have hit that for most operations
also for Farmers that are running
particularly heavy operations some of
our customers on the larger scale and
the more industrial operations may want
to run 16 hours a day so our Battery
Technology we have a swappable battery
pack so we have an infield battery swap
system that enables you to do that so if
you really need to run 16 hours a day we
have a technical solution for that these
power ports allow us to provide energy
out of the middle of the farm we are
here and there's not a single energy
source that you can actually find
so farmers usually are dragging out
generators and then dragging out you
know Jerry cans to fill up those
generators with diesel again whereas
with our tractor thanks to our big
battery you have energy on demand
you can also using our features summon
the tractor to provide energy so if
you're out in the middle of somewhere
you want to run some lights or something
else like Carlos talking about
we can actually using the app get the
tractor out
plug whatever you want in to the Tractor
and then power
all the not only lights but also other
attachments and implements can be
powered from the tractor
you know oftentimes we pick in the
middle of the night time and the tractor
is making this loud noise and you
realize the only reason the tractor
engine is rumbling is to keep the lights
on so these lights allow us to basically
see when we're working at night time but
with a quiet calm no gas polluting way
which is really quite lovely yeah
[Music]
California state incentives for electric
tractors can offset as much as 75
percent of the cost of a vehicle like
monarchs there's another potential
roadblock to consider
California regulations don't yet allow
tractors to be fully autonomous they
still require a human operator to tag
along Monarch has petitioned for full
autonomy and the state has agreed to
reconsider after it collects more safety
data I think the safety part of Monarch
tractor is one of the most incredible
things the most dangerous place on the
farm is in the tractor seat and so by
being able to automate farming you're
able to essentially remove armors from
the most dangerous place on the farm
there's so many things that come with
this also if you are driving there's a
lot of things like the ability for us to
see where the tractor is going and
what's happening even with an operator
in it and allow for the tractor to stop
if you know an operator hypothetically
falls asleep or something like this so
there's lots of collision prevention
built into the tractor and then
obviously when it's operating
autonomously it can see everything and
like we were talking about it has 360
degree Vision so anything that comes
within a few meters it'll the tractor
will stop send an alert to the farm
manager saying hey this is in my path is
it okay to continue going for it or
should I stop and the farm manager can
say no that's good you're continue on or
duly noted if it's something that comes
into the path it'll honk at it it'll say
hey get out of my way
person can get out of the way and then
the tractor will continue on but if it
stays there it'll send the alert on the
safety side the fact that we are
removing like Carlos said the driver
from the most dangerous place on the
farm which is the driver's seat
also means that less exposure to
chemicals
less exposure to the elements and this
is a dull dirty dangerous job which is
why we are having a shortage
of tractor drivers whether it's in
California or around the world
so I was in an Indian village and there
were only like two people in the whole
village who could operate tractors
the reason for that is it's a very
skilled job but it's also a dull dirty
dangerous job so people would rather
work in construction or do other skill
labor stuff which is you know much
easier on them so at the end of the day
what our technology allows us to do is
to
make it more of a creative job takes
them away from the seat puts them back
in the barn
where they can really monitor a fleet of
these tractors and also take care of all
the attachments and implements and prep
all these things so that we can do more
on our Farms while being safe and that's
the game changer
you know this that California is the
most agriculture intensive state in the
country there's more dairy in California
than there is in Wisconsin and so for
that reason we're in the perfect place
to start this company our customers in
the vineyard Orchard and dairy space are
all perfect for the first product that
we're releasing also from an incentive
perspective California has programs to
make sure that the incentives offered to
the farmer to be able to adopt our
product are really World leading the
other thing that we have to be thankful
for in California especially the
California energy commission for helping
us set up our manufacturing operations
here in the state which helps us
expedite development as well as scale
here in California I'm a fourth
generation farmer winemaker they've
always said you're a steward of this
land it's not your land you're working
on protecting this land for the Next
Generation
to try to elevate everything and leave
the planet in a better place or this
piece of land in a better place then
then you received it one of the reasons
why I join this incredible movement at
Monarch tractor was because I needed the
technology so it wasn't something like
oh I'm gonna build this and try to sell
this to a farmer like we all desperately
need this technology if the question is
really how how affordable can we make
this so that every Farm can afford this
like how can we scale this as quickly as
possible when I talk to Farmers I know
their pain points because they're the
pain points that I have
admitsa believes he could sell tens of
thousands of tractors and reach Revenue
in the hundreds of millions of dollars
within three years enabling Monarch to
go public then he ultimately hopes to
make a cheaper version too that could
sell for less than fifteen thousand
dollars in Asia and Africa having come
from India and having grown up in an
agriculture family I'm very close to the
challenges that the global farmer faces
and that's really where we feel like our
impact can be massive is in countries
like India and in continents like Africa
but starting this new technology
development in Asia or Africa is not
going to allow us to validate the tech
and scale it like most Technologies we
felt like we had to you know incubate it
in California make sure that we develop
it here and then once it's mature or
like mini spark Technologies and even
electric cars these days we can then
take it back to Asia and then make it
very accessible at a lower cost and a
much more usable configurations one of
the great thing about transformational
Technologies is what works in one
country very often has to be modified
especially from a business model
standpoint and go to market strategy
when we go to other countries we saw
that with the cell phones you know where
once you went to India you saw pay as
you go minutes we got you know single
text message charges
so the fact that use as you go models
are more prevalent
in Asia and Africa and are ways to get
expensive but valuable Technologies into
users hands means that our tractor also
is going to see more traction
in a pay-as-you-go model so what we have
done with that is we are partnered up
with local infrastructure companies in
those areas who can use our tractor as
energy storage
but can also help basically act as an
aggregator of demand and finance the
whole capex so that the end user only
pays for the time that they used without
having to carry this capex burden and
this model has been extremely successful
when we look at things like electric
buses in India or other smart components
in India so our tractor is also going to
be one of those devices with a very
different use case and a very different
business model
[Music]
people are pessimists say that oh we're
not going to be able to address climate
change so let's just keep driving 180
degrees right into the wrong direction
right or these chemicals are making life
easier so let's just keep using them
let's keep going down that old Route and
from a consumer basis when they don't
really care about farming or they don't
seem to like really appreciate I think
it's just because of a lack of
connection and if you don't have that
connection to farming I think it's easy
to dismiss it because you just don't
know it's just like people with climate
change when they say oh I don't believe
in climate change well wait till climate
change comes at your doorstep and we'll
talk about it my fear is that if we
don't course correct on every aspect of
every single sector of our planets
industry that's associated with Humanity
if we don't course correct the next
generation will be stuck with something
so uncontrollable that they can't they
can't pivot I would like to be able to
be a part of course correcting that and
being a part of the change that allows
for
us to be able to pass on this planet to
the Next Generation in a way that that's
manageable that the biodiversity instead
of being in Decline is coming back that
our soils are healthier that the
waterways are healthier that our food is
healthier and that our life is better
and that's what we're working towards
here at Monarch and I would love for
this to be that pivotal moment in time
where that changes in one sector and I
I'd like to see that happen across all
sectors but I'm happy to be working on
it in this one